I've been doing more and more Facebook
live streams and I hope that you do like
us on Facebook facebook.com slash david
pakman show because we answer questions
I take questions from people who are
watching the live stream and do a lot of
stuff that we just don't have time for
on the Regular Show people have asked
what's my setup for the Facebook live
streams and I was actually recently sent
the callee ProGear flexible tripod which
is for GoPros mirrorless and
point-and-shoot cameras and this is part
of my setup for the Facebook live
streams it's super versatile it can be
used in a ton of different ways and as I
mentioned it comes with a GoPro mount I
don't currently have a GoPro I know a
lot of people in our audience have
GoPros and love it and the segmented
legs allow you to mount it really almost
anywhere I mean you can wrap it around a
bike pole you can wrap it around a table
as I demonstrate here and it's one of
the ways that it's way better than the
old little portable tripods I had
woodwork where I had a really hard time
just getting it to stay where I needed
it it also is super light it's rugged
it's easy to use you basically just if
you're using the GoPro mount you just
screw it into the top and put the GoPro
on if you're not you attach the small
mounting plate to the bottom of any
camera that has a standard tripod mount
and once you have that mounting plate on
you basically just put the thing on the
tripod and and that's really it it's a
universal screw it's a quick-release
head so you can easily attach the camera
to the tripod mount and this is now also
going to be my setup when I broadcast
remotely from conferences yeah I
broadcast from Las Vegas twice a year
super super easy to use and there I am
doing a facebook livestream showing
people a look behind the curtain very
very interesting I know that many people
wonder what is it like when I'm doing
these streams it's really pretty boring
I'm just basically talking into a camera
but the callee ProGear flexible tripod
makes it much much easier and of course
it comes with a hundred percent lifetime
money-back guarantee thanks to them for
sponsoring this